Today I'm teaching my brother how to
start day trading with just $4. But
instead of a normal tutorial, I'm
literally walking him through everything
live, setting up his account, showing
him how to actually read the market, how
to grow a small trading account, just
starting with $4, and then answering
every beginner question he has along the
way. That was one of my questions going
back that can resistance levels become
supports like floors.
>> But more importantly, I'm focusing on
what actually matters step by step so he
doesn't get overloaded trying to learn
everything at once. He learns things in
the proper order. I've never made a
video like this before, but if you
follow along, it's going to give you a
much better foundation than most
beginners have, and most beginner
trading videos give you, even my own.
So, let's get my brother and you set up
the right way to become a consistently
profitable and confident trader. So,
like, yeah, this is the trade I took
what, two days ago now, at this point.
And it's like this is basically what I'm
just trying to do every morning is
looking for the market. You know, this
is Eastern time. Like charts are always
in Eastern time now. So it just opens
here at 9:30.
>> Yeah. And then ideally like looking for
I'll just get out of this so it doesn't
you know like this big move down into a
spot where it looks like it's going to
reverse and then looking for you know
cuz that just gives you much more like
room for a trade to play out in your
favor you know and and you can have
small riskreward. I always find trying
to stay with the trend like if you think
it's going to continue down here it's
really hard to understand where like the
riskreward will go. there's not like an
easy target versus here and we'll talk
about later. It's very often you can say
where this move started is where if it
reverses it'll end like so that's super
easy target and easy to figure out your
riskreward and
>> how much room you have in it.
>> Yeah. and and so you can do the math and
everything. And so, you know, it's just
spotting that unhealthy move and then
like kind of looking for a bottoming
pattern that we'll get into a little bit
later. And then just kind of trying to
like ride it out and manage it. And you
know, I I don't want to get too into
like entry and managing, but just kind
of like this is trying to repeat this
consistently every day and and looking
for just this one thing has made it like
super simple for me and a ton of other
people in just being able to master one
thing versus trying to
>> Yeah. do it consistently.
>> Yeah. Get bogged down in so many
different styles and everything.
>> Yeah.
>> And and so this is pretty much where it
got knocked out. And this was way longer
than normal. Usually on my trades are
like 20 minutes, but I think this yellow
line, I think I drew that later. But
just to look at the target, I guess like
6,965
is
>> that number on the side, that's ticks.
>> The points, I guess. Yeah. Mainly
points. Ticks would be the the main
>> the little sub ones. Okay.
>> Yeah. Between like this 0.25, that's a
tick.
>> Got it. And those are always in 0.25s.
>> Yeah. For for the ES. Uh, but so, you
know, I want to try and like figure out
and teach you like the best way to
approach this in a methodical way that
you can slowly build up.
>> Huh.
>> That I can reproduce.
>> Yeah. and that you can like slowly cuz I
think there's so many ways to get
distracted and and trying to focus on
the key pillars of what makes a
profitable trader and it's easy to get
bogged down in the like the canal sticks
and stuff and and try and enter and and
manage a trade perfectly when there's
really like the first most important
thing is just looking like for this
first week I think the best thing for
you to do is we can just start to teach
you and you can practice literally just
looking at like major trad trends in the
market because the like final entry of
where you jump in doesn't really matter
if you can't pick the general thesis
that it's going to reverse here. You
know, if you're wrong about that, you
could enter in here and it could be
great, but it could just reverse at some
point and continue lower going lower.
And that's like understanding the big
picture.
>> Yeah. One of the one of the notes I took
from going through your course earlier
this week was like you were talking
about one minute versus five minute
charts and how the five-minute chart
really just like reduces a lot of the
noise. It's like if you're looking at it
too closely, you're going to get too
much noise.
>> Yeah.
>> I thought that was helpful for trying to
like identify the larger patterns or
moves.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, definitely use that
and look at that in a second. I mean, I
think even like here like this kind of
noise here could get you in trouble. And
there's definitely other times like in
choppier markets where you can start
looking at it too much and and get
sucked in and think it's something could
happen and really it's just you should
stay out which is why like yeah going to
the bigger trends can be helpful.
>> Yeah. I have a question on the first 30
minutes I guess. So one of the things
you were talking about earlier was an
unhealthy move and I'm wondering how
much in the first 30 minutes is that an
unhealthy move or just the market
figuring out what it's doing? cuz I know
you talk a lot about 30 minutes after
opening, so at 10:00 a.m. roughly, it
makes a change in momentum or trend.
>> Yeah.
>> And so I'm wondering how much of it is
like that first 30 minutes here. Is that
unhealthy or just the market figuring
out what it's doing and then it
reverses?
>> I mean, I think what we're going to go
over later is like we'll help with that
is okay.
>> Is how to like identify okay, what is
how do you tell the difference between
this being a healthy trend or a strong
trend? Yeah,
>> that it's, you know, it's going to fail
in reverse here versus continue to go
down. And obviously, like you can't
predict that every time, but there's
definitely like good signals and reasons
to be able to try and predict that. Like
the other important thing of this first
week is like just getting used to the
schedule.
>> Yeah.
>> Just getting used to the schedule of I
kind of wrote it down here a little bit
of like opening your charts like 15
minutes before the market, which would
be, you know, 9:15 Eastern Standard
Time. So then in those first 15 minutes,
it gives you time to kind of just look
at, you know, the major swings of the
market, like what's going on kind of
thing of seeing like, okay, what
overnight or in the past like day has
the market, you know, if it's Monday,
like in the past weekend, like what has
the market done? And so like where do I
see kind of the main levels and moves
that have happened? So I can look at
kind of the big big picture going into
the day. So you can kind of figure out
that bias. And then as well, I like to
where's this chart at? This will work.
Drawing those major swings. And then
going into I'll just because it's the
weekend right now, but go into when the
market's going to open. I like to draw
vertical lines at just the 15 minutes
after the open and like the the 30
minutes after the open. So 9:45 and 10
a.m. because those are key news times
where the market will do something a lot
of the time. And just like so it it
allows you to again like put like a v
easy visual thing on the chart that'll
as you watch like you know the
candlesticks come up into that area you
can say okay it's hitting this I can
kind of like I know that's a spot where
something could potentially happen
>> more likely to do something there.
>> Yeah. I I find that it really helps me
like stay more focused on, you know, the
strategy you're trying to execute versus
just reacting to the market because
that's such an easy thing to get into of
just like reacting to the market versus
waiting for it to come to you.
>> Yeah. Well, yeah.
>> Yeah. And then and then the idea is
you're probably going to be at the
charts for like an hour at least, like
until, you know, 10:15 Eastern, just
because that gets it to that 10:00 a.m.
time, you know, where that it's likely
to do something. And then a lot of times
either the move will happen or you just
won't have a good read on the market or
it just won't be a good market. Yeah.
>> And I like to then just kind of be done
with trading for the day cuz you've come
in, you've looked for, you know, your
specific strategy and that time window
of opportunity and then if it doesn't
show up, the idea is just moving on for
the day versus trying to stick around
and like force something to happen. Do
you ever look at it like two hours later
just to see if it's like similar to
looking at it at like I guess what it be
6:15 my time. So 9:15 like 15 minutes
before the open. Just look at it like a
couple hours later just to see if it's
changing or resetting up or like market
behaviors.
>> The other like last main reversal time I
would say is 11 a.m. Eastern. So, you
could, you know, some if something
doesn't happen at 10:00 a.m., you could,
you know, be done at 10:15, go like for
a walk with your dog for like 45
minutes. Yeah.
>> Come back, you know, get some food or
whatever. Take a break basically with
the idea that I'm going to take a break.
>> Reset my brain.
>> Yeah. Reset your brain so you're not
just staring at the charts and getting
impatient and more likely to just do
something stupid. But, you know, then
you come back and you, you know, you're
following your plan of like, okay, I'm
gonna, I'm just going to see has the
market, yeah, like you're saying, has
it, you know, come up to somewhere at,
you know, 11, which would be all the way
here. And it's like, okay, has it done
something? Because that's, you know, an
hour of time a lot can happen.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's just the other time where
I've noticed that it can kind of top out
and reverse or or change. And then after
that, like I mean, you know, there's
people that trade all day, but I always
find that it's easier to trade for
shorter amount of times because you can
kind of be laser focused and you're not
going to overdo it. And you know, like
you say,
>> burn out.
>> Yeah. Because it's it seems a lot really
easy to think about it, but then when
you're actually doing it, there's just
so many micro decisions you're
constantly making that it's just super
draining. And even just the micro
decisions to stay out and do nothing is
still very draining. Yeah.
>> And I think another thing about that
first week is I guess this is like
working on not actually
>> doing anything while you're trading.
Yeah. Like
>> not like going and doing, you know, I
don't know, looking at something else on
our screen like either like I like I
used to, you know, play video games,
watch YouTube, or even like do some work
related thing. And there were so many
times where I'd look back at the chart
and I would have missed something or I
would yeah
>> think I was about to miss something and
do an impulsive trade because it's so
much easier to FOMO and think you're oh
I just this massive candle just popped
up and I'm going to miss something
because you're not really thinking about
the market and thinking oh that if I see
a big candlestick here I think it's a
bait or something.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And you know there's I still like
what I do is like I well I think trading
like a short amount of time makes that
easier but then also like listening to
music or like trying to find that fine
line between something that kind of
keeps you occupied but your brain can
still be thinking about the charts in a
way.
>> Yeah. like either music or like
stretching or doing push-ups or
something versus like, you know, and I
stand at my desk, you know, I think
sitting is way easier to kind of just
get more kind of just like sluggish and
not engaged.
>> That makes sense.
>> Yeah. Any like questions on like
schedule or any of that kind of stuff?
>> I don't think so. It definitely will be
the like hardest initial hurdle for me.
Yeah,
>> cuz being on the West Coast and not
being a fully committed morning morning
person. Uh,
>> but no, I mean it's something I've
known. It's something I like I would
like to wake up earlier anyways. So,
this just gives me a better reason to
wake up rather than just waking up for
the sake of waking up.
>> Yeah. Oh, go ahead.
>> Yeah. No, no initial questions on like
scheduling or schedule. I don't know
like a rough time but like I think you
know I think this depends for every
person but like waking up with enough
time to wake up before trading so it's
like I had to struggle on the West Coast
too with like okay if you wake up an
hour before market that's 5:30 that
blows.
>> Yeah.
>> Like in an ideal world going and doing
like a workout before trading just to
get your blood really flowing would be
sick. But
>> 10 minutes kind of thrusters.
>> I mean honestly like I definitely think
it's ideal like I've even done here of
like going for a run for like just a
mile.
>> Yeah.
>> Just something to get your blood going
and get you kind of awake. And you know
sometimes I don't do that either. Like I
just kind of get up but like giving
yourself at least like I think 30 to 45
minutes before the market opens is
ideal.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Just to fully wake up.
>> Yeah. And of course that's kind of like
person dependent. Yeah. I think we can
do next is try and just get charts set
up and like talk about charts and talk
about trends and like what what you
should try and be focusing on and
reading in the first week or two.
>> Getting it set up would be super good
cuz I followed along a little bit with
one of your tutorials, but then I was
like, this seems far ahead from what I
should be doing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, we can totally go
through just like a a simple one. Do you
have the link for or do you have like an
account already set up? I have an
account already set up
>> and we're just going to use Ninja Trader
for anyone else that wants to use what
we're using too. I'll just leave a link
for in this description below and we're
technically going to be trading futures,
but honestly like we're not even going
to talk about that in the first week or
two cuz I think you don't even, you
know, it's like charts are charts. Like
you can use this kind of stuff on
anything. You don't need to, you know,
really get into the nitty-gritty. Again,
it's it's trying to focus on the big
picture first. I'll try. Do you want me
to share my screen or
>> I'm assuming you just have a blank
slate, right? Like you just have this
window cuz I can just you can just
follow along and I can just do it which
will probably work too.
>> Okay, I see which window that is. I have
that window pops up and then like four
other little charts pop up every time.
>> Okay, I think you can try and close
those out.
>> Okay,
>> let's see. try and I think do close
those out and go to workspaces here and
click new
>> workspaces
>> because I think this will help like set
up
>> okay yeah what should I call it
>> I don't know whatever you want cuz
that'll I think that just that might
actually reset everything and make it
like a new workspace and all you need to
do is just go to new up here and then
chart
>> and that kind of like pulls up this
window and then there should be a
drop-own menu here I don't think you'll
have these so you want to go to futures
And then you can just go to ES and it
should have a number next to it. That's
just like the expiration month.
>> Okay. Yeah, I have ES December 25.
>> Okay. You can you can just click that
and then you can always just like write
in you can just delete this and write in
03. Maybe not here. Oh yeah, it does
work. Yeah, you can just literally just
type it in. Usually normally like Ninja
Trader will give you a prompt to
automatically roll over so you don't
really have to think about it cuz you
know it'll it'll expire and go on to
next a different contract number.
>> Okay. I have ES December 25. Which did
you rename?
>> I literally just clicked on this box
right here and just deleted it and typed
in ES03-26
and press enter.
>> When I do that, I get a little weird
data is delayed box next to it. Oh, it's
cuz you your free trial ran out. I would
ran out probably if you made your
account like, you know, weeks or months
ago.
>> I opened this under sim.
>> I don't I don't Well, with your delayed
data, I don't know why it would
>> I think some of it said it was
>> I don't know how that works.
>> There's like a 15minute data delay.
>> Like that should be fine. You should
still be able to select this correct
instrument though. Do all these say 12
instead of three?
>> If I go to futures. Yeah, they all 1220
or 1225.
>> Uh ZW,
ZN, ZB, those are all 26. GC is 26. CL
20 Jan 26. My ES is December 25, though.
>> What about your NQ?
>> NQ December 20. Same thing.
>> I mean, maybe you just have to go get
data. I mean, you're going to have to do
it at some point anyway.
>> Yeah.
>> So, just go to ninjatrader.com and log
in.
>> What if I told you I don't see that?
Okay. Go up here. Go to settings. I was
just in the Yeah, it had the old style
and then it said open legacy. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I know. It looked a little
funny actually. Yeah. So, go to settings
first and then you'll see up here and
Okay. And then you probably won't see
all this cuz this is mine set up.
>> Oh, I have market data. It says CNB
bundle level one status inactive.
>> Well, how much does it say it is?
>> That one's $12 per month. I also just
have account plan. You should be able to
Yeah. If you find like the subscription,
you should be able to um do Can you get
to this page when you click like manage
subscription?
>> That's for market data subscription.
Okay. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I have an update
subscription, but it should be some kind
of like market data subscription.
>> Yeah. It looks like I just subscribe to
it.
>> Yeah. But then it gives these. Go click
here. Go to just the customize drop down
here and it puts all this cuz then you
can you should be able to Yeah. You
should be able to just do this one. CME
for $4 per month. Let me just double
check. I always get these mixed up.
Yeah. So, this has the ES and the NASDAQ
and I don't think it has if other people
are like wanting to trade gold and oil
and stuff, you're going to have to do I
think Comix. I think this has Yeah, this
has gold, silver, all your like
minerals. And then oil actually might be
in a different one. So, if you just
Yeah, like it's it's if you need to do
all these, like I'm subscribed to just
this one for 12 a month that just all of
them, but if you're just like like for
you now, like it's better to just start
on
>> Yeah, that sounds like a problem for
later.
>> Yeah. Like it's better to just focus on
just like the ES and the NASDAQ. And I
think I've slowly over time just doing
like I'm just doing that because it's
just again simpler is always better. So
like you can easily just $4 a month is
super cheap for data. A lot of places
charge you more.
>> Oh, I just want ES, right? ES March 26.
>> Yeah. So, you got this finally. It says
now that you updated it, you can just
see this is all like 03.
>> You charge us 26. Okay.
>> Cuz if not, another thing to do if it
you can go to tools here and go to
database management under tools. Just
database management. It's like the third
one. And you can click this rollover
button. If there's some that are like
not updated, generally like it'll
automatically do it. And so you won't
really have to do this, but if you ever
like need to, it's an easy way to do it.
>> Okay. I have opened a chart. Um
>> Oh, you weren't supposed to open a chart
yet.
>> I've closed a chart.
>> There's still some stuff over here. We
have
>> Wait, I don't see where do I see that
now?
>> What?
>> That screen. So if I hit If I Okay, if I
go to my workspace and hit my I named it
trading with Riley. by How do I get to
that screen that you're on?
>> This one. It should just You're going to
have to go down to like on your tabs cuz
it's a different window.
>> Okay. It's different.
>> Oh, you're under you're under accounts.
Okay, gotcha. Okay, I'm there.
>> Oh, I mean like Yeah, this doesn't
really matter. Like you can just It's
just the the top things are the same.
That's all you really need. Okay. Yeah.
So, we're here. We have this selected.
And this is like how you open a chart
generally. Generally, it's like this is
just like it's a minute chart. And then
>> I'm sorry. I'm gonna be
>> what?
>> Oh, you're just under data series.
>> Do you What are you looking?
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah, I know. I see what
you're talking about. Okay, I'm there.
>> I guess first it's like you can we can
do like a 15. Change the value to 15.
So, it's a 15minute chart.
>> Yeah.
>> And then days to load. I like to just do
50.
>> Yeah.
>> And then I think just this should
automatically say does this
automatically say use instrument
settings?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I like to click break at end of
day. That little toggle button below it.
If that's not
>> Yeah.
>> You have to kind of tell me if these are
different. I don't know. bar width. I
think that's probably normal. And then
the colors I changed to basically have
up bars be white and down bars be blue
versus and then the outline of the
bodies. I think you might have to change
that too just to simple like white or
something. And the idea with having
them, you know, a different colors,
those are a lot more calming. Like
having red and and green candlesticks is
very emotionally triggering. It just
yeah helps keep it to where it's like
it's you know just red and green are
just very emotional colors and so
reducing as much triggering input as
possible really helps and I think that
should be it. Other stuff like is just
Yeah, you can. So you can just press
okay and that should open up a chart
like this.
>> Yeah, mine looks the same.
>> Okay, you need to rightclick just
anywhere on the chart and pull up
properties.
>> Yep. And then so just like there's not
too much on here, but like right side
margin is how much space there is right
here between the chart. So like if you
want more space there, it's kind of just
personal preference like visually you
can change this. So it's like it
automatically forces a lot of space to
to be on the right side. I usually have
it at like I don't know 300 400. Again,
that's some like preference you can kind
of change over time, but 300 is like a
good just visually having a little space
there is kind of nice. And I think the
other main things is just these grid
lines. You can open these up and just
make them visible. Just kind of helps
when you're looking at the chart. And
we'll have one more setting that will
that'll help add to this. Then we know
when you got that done. And you might
have to I I don't know if your colors
are the same, but I've always kind of
made them, you know, it's again
preference of like not having them stand
out too much. Yeah, mine are slightly
different color, but that's fine for
now.
>> Okay, I think that's everything there.
Last thing for grid lines is see this
button up here? It's called chart
trader.
>> Yep.
>> Toggle that on. Do the middle option.
>> Is that like center it? No,
>> it'll it'll pull up the side panel.
>> I look like I have more, let's see,
vertical lines. I look like I have two
to one.
>> Well,
>> or you just weren't zoomed in very much.
>> They just adjust. Yeah, they're like on
scaling.
>> Okay.
>> Once you have this up, you want to right
click on it.
>> Yeah. and then properties. Yeah. And
then go to I guess we'll do this now.
Some of this will be pertinent to later.
Oh, I actually don't know. Yeah, I think
you want this one set to here. We'll
double check that probably when we get
more closer to trading, but then I think
this should just be I think just this
makes sense as default settings for
this. Just having this on on points
versus like money or anything makes it
so you're kind of just focusing.
>> Yeah. You're not paying attention to the
dollar amount.
>> Yeah. And then like having this off too.
This will show how much you're up and
down. Like it it changes this to be, you
know, zero or up or down money. You also
don't need that. And then here's like
later you can change a bunch of this
stuff, but it's mainly personal
preference. Right click the axis and
properties. Oh, I see. We didn't even
need to go to this. I'm just going to
turn that off. Yeah, you can turn this
off. I might just cut that whole section
out. We don't need that right now.
>> Especially because we left everything as
default.
>> I know. I was like, "Wait, what?"
>> So, all right. Next up, we go to this
part and we leave everything default.
>> We also won't need it until you start
trading.
>> I thought this setting was in there that
we're looking for.
>> Okay, last thing for the grid lines. Go
right click on your axis, Yaxis, and
then go to properties and then change
this the horizontal grid lines here. So
change it to fixed and then just leave
it at points and one point. And so what
that does is it puts a horizontal line
every point. And so it allows you to
really visually easily see the velocity
of the market. Like if you if I just
like scroll to the side right here and
zoom in.
>> Yeah. It gives you a fixed point of
reference rather than
>> as we were talking about earlier where
it was scaling all the time.
>> Yeah. Like here it's like you can see
the lines are a lot closer. So you can
tell that the market's moving a lot
faster versus I mean like here it's
moving it's there's been a ton of
volatility recently but like if I zoomed
in here you can tell okay it's not
moving that fast.
>> Yeah.
>> And then that should be so this will be
the idea is this is your 15minute chart
that you open up. This is kind of the
first thing you're looking at every
morning and you're coming in here and
saying, "Okay, I am going to, you know,
look for my my major support and
resistance zones that we'll talk about
in a second, too." And like any like
trend lines that I see going on, stuff
like that. So, this is like your
15-minute chart. And so, what you can
do, what I like to do is down here in
the like super bottom left, the little
tab right here.
>> Yeah.
>> You can rightclick it and just rename
it. When you right click, you And then
where is the name? Oh, tab name. And
then I I just like to say 15 minute
chart. Actually, I usually do ES because
it's the E. We're looking at ES right
now. And then just 15 minute chart
because then that'll then once you have
all these charts up, you can easily find
them when you're trying to go through
your windows and tabbing through them.
>> Yeah.
>> And then once you got that, right click
on it again and do duplicate a new tab.
And then that'll completely keep all
your settings. And then you can just go
up to the top left and change it to or
you can just honestly just type in here,
type in NQ and it'll do it and it'll
pull up the NASDAQ.
>> Should I be looking at the NASDAQ at all
to start? I know you're talking about
how one of them slightly follows the
other, but I think it was the NASDAQ is
more volatile. I think it was NASDAQ
follows ES to some extent, but is more
volatile or changes in some way. Yeah.
No, I think it's okay to I think it's
good to look at both. I think the idea
is you could focus on just only when we
get down to it only trading the ES, but
I think a good confirmation that I use a
lot of the time is are the NASDAQ and
the ES aligned? Because if they're kind
of moving similarly, they're more likely
to be easy to read, easy to predict, and
easy to kind of like actually do a
successful trade versus sometimes you'll
have the NASDAQ kind of doing some crazy
move up and the ES will be just kind of
chopping. And I've realized over time
like you don't want to be trading when
they're kind of each other. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, just kind of like another
indicator to be like, all right,
everything is moving in the same
direction.
>> Yeah, it's it's Yeah, it's a really good
indicator for that. Um, last thing is
just right clicking on this and renaming
it.
>> Yeah, I did.
>> Okay. Yeah, just to NASDAQ. You could
just do NQ or you could say NASDAQ.
Whatever your preference is. And then
and then we just need to Yeah, go ahead.
>> Really? This is a dumb question. How do
I get the background lines to be more
opaque?
>> You should be able to just go to
rightclick and properties and then the
grid line. Mine are just a dark color.
That's why it's like, you know, versus
if you have like a full white
>> maybe. Yeah, mine's a silver.
>> That's horrible.
>> Yeah, like usually their like default
background like back I think mine has
background medium or something. It's
pretty good. And you could also make
your chart background like darker. I
think a big thing is some of those
colors get changed in
>> Oh, I don't have all the dim gray.
>> Yeah, if you go let me see. I think if
you go to Yeah. Go to your Can you come
to here again? Go to tools. Just the
normal
>> can do that. Yeah, just pull up the
normal Ninja Trader window. And if you
go to settings,
>> tool settings. Yep.
>> And then on general, just right here at
the bottom of this page, you don't have
to scroll down. Mine's on Ninja Trader.
>> Ninja Trader Dark. Okay.
>> Is yours What's yours? Not.
>> It was just on regular Ninja Trader.
>> Okay. So, that's how you Yeah, you get
the darker colors. You will have to
restart to make that change,
>> but that'll probably just make your
charts like much darker.
>> Yeah. If you don't do that, dim gray
also works really well.
>> Okay. Okay. So, these are like big
picture charts that we're like I I
really just look at these like initially
and then as I'm trading I'm really just
looking at like a five minute and a one
minute which we'll we can make in a
next. So, I I just go right click again
at these tabs down here and go duplicate
a new window, not new tab.
>> Oh, okay. Fancy.
>> And then all we do is just change this
the 15 minute up here. this dropdown.
Just change it to a one minute. And then
change the name. Just take out the five.
Change it to a one minute. And then we
also want to turn on the chart trader up
here.
>> One second. I was busy jumping ahead and
making one for ES.
>> Oh, I mean I can do that, too.
>> Okay. What do I What do we need to do?
>> Say change it to 1 minute.
>> Yeah, I did that.
>> And then just open the chart trader.
>> Chart trader. Okay.
>> And then you could you can make it full
screen, whatever works. I'm just going
to keep it a little smaller because it's
easier for me right now. Yeah. And then
just duplicate in new tab. And we'll
actually change this to a five minute.
>> Okay.
>> Change it to a five minute. And then
rename just put the five in there. I
like to do it this way to where it
depends totally on how many monitors you
have and what like your setup is. But
often I'll have and then just before I
get to that, I'll duplicate this again
and duplicate like duplicate the one
minute and the five minute again and
then change these to NASDAQ. So then
basically you have a one minute of the
NASDAQ, a one minute of the ES, and then
a five minute of them as well. And so
it's all on one window. Oh, I've messed
that up. So you can easily just look
through them on one kind of tab on one
screen. So really, it's like, okay, I'm
going to be trading this one window on
the this is like where I enter. The one
minute is where I enter. And then I can
confirm on the five minute of kind of
like what's the the more medium picture
looking like. It kind of helped drown
out the noise. And then you can also do
the same thing with the NASDAQ one
minute and the five minute to help
control kind of what you're seeing.
>> Okay.
>> All set.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I have my six different
tabs.
>> Yeah. And like your two windows and then
it's really easy to like on Windows at
least is like to mouse over and be like,
"Okay, I want to pull up my one minute
or 15 minute." Like if you're on a one
single monitor or if like you get lost,
like usually I have a couple other ones
open. Like the other one I'll have
sometimes open when I'm trading is, you
know, I'll have main ES one minute chart
on my main screen and then I'll have if
I just duplicate a NASDAQ one minute,
I'll have this also kind of smaller on
another monitor just to like when you're
really trading and like entering in, I
can be like watching each little
candlestick develop and see like, okay,
is that aligning up with what I'm seeing
for like, you know, confirmation on
They're both moving in the same
direction.
>> Yeah. Um when you really get down to the
nitty-gritty, but again, like, you know,
we can talk we'll talk more about that
later.
>> That sounds like next week's problem.
>> Yeah. Or a couple weeks problem.
>> Or a couple weeks problem.
>> Yeah. Cuz that's definitely like a
little more advanced. So, and I mean
like you don't technically you don't
need if you don't want you can turn off
the chart traders for any of these
windows.
>> Okay. What is the chart trader? It's
like when you're actually trading and
we'll get down to that. When you're
trading, it's like it's how you
>> enter. Okay. Yeah, I see quantity.
>> And it also brings up like these lines
on the chart. Like it brings these up
and so it allows you to like actively
manage on the chart.
>> Aren't those specifically are Oh, are
those your plugin or your indicator or
are those the base ones and then your
riskreward is the
>> No, these are the base ones.
>> Okay. you know. Yeah. Like my my add-ons
I have that like the two main ones that
I use are like this click trader that
pulls up to here and then it allows me
to just like I can't really do it right
now and we'll get to it later but allows
like to like with with literally a click
of a mouse like enter in an order.
>> Yeah,
>> it's kind of spazzing out because the
market is right now
>> and it's broken.
>> And it's broken.
>> Yeah, that sounds like it'll be good to
go through later on.
>> I might have to start restart my
platform. Oh, there we go. It kind of
the market's closed right now so it kind
of spazzes it out. Yeah. And then then
this risk tool. Yeah. We'll definitely
go into that when we like talk more
about entry.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Those are super important.
>> Yeah. Because they look very helpful and
I would like to use them.
>> Yeah. So with I guess Yeah. Like so
>> can you hear Tucker?
>> Not really.
>> Okay.
>> I heard
>> it's going off.
>> So now we're all like set up. I This is
kind of personal preference too actually
is you can right click on the chart for
properties and just change the font
size. Like I would say this is kind of
small, but again it's personal
preference of like how big your screen
is and like what your I also kind of
have it big just for like recording
purposes.
>> Where did you click?
>> Just right click anywhere on the chart
and go to properties.
>> Oh, I see. Okay. Oh, I don't I don't see
that as something I can change.
>> It's like this little
>> Oh, I see. I see. I see.
>> It's a little confusing. It doesn't look
like something's there. Yeah.
>> What does that change the numbers on the
side?
>> Yeah. And then when you're like in a
trade, it's those profit numbers to No,
I just lost my train thought.
>> How to draw trends.
>> Yeah, I guess so.
>> Or is there any more setup we need to
initially do?
>> No, I think we can get into like Yeah.
your your your basics. Let's pull up the
15-minute chart and just try and go like
kind of more methodically of like, you
know, the first thing you're going to do
is like be looking at the big picture,
right? And so I guess another setup
thing for that is you can pull this up
by just right clicking on the chart and
seeing drawing tools right here. Yeah,
>> it'll pull up all your drawing tools.
There's also a button up here, this
little pencil at the top left. And I
like to just use hotkeys because it's
super easy. And so if you go pull up the
main control window again, you can go to
tools and go to hotkeys.
>> Okay. Main control window. Tools.
Hotkeys. Yep.
>> And then yeah, you just the first one
will be chart and then scroll all the
way down really cuz that's where at
least down to where you see drawings
halfway down.
>> Yep.
>> Let's see. We want to go to It's kind of
hard to There's only a couple I use. I
think line right here. I have You just
click on it and then it and then click
the button you want. I like F2. You
can't do F1 because that's like the
Ninja Trader hotkey button. If you press
F1 on any window, any like thing you
have selected, it'll literally
automatically bring up like a Ninja
Trader like help window of like that
section. So like that's kind of helpful
for certain things. But so yeah, F2 for
that and then rectangle I have this F3.
That's how I draw my like support and
resistance zones.
>> So it's already in use by chart line. Do
I care about chart line?
>> No, just override what if it says like
it's in use by something else.
>> Oh yeah, I was dumb. It was also ray.
Okay. And then so and then vertical line
all the way at the bottom. I do F6.
Again, like you can change these to what
makes more sense later. And then you
probably won't have this, but maybe you
have it as just the normal riskreward,
but when we get you set up with that,
you'll want to come in and change that
as F4. So maybe I don't know if I don't
know what you have right there right
now, but when you get the risk
indicator,
>> how far down was that?
>> All the way at the bottom.
>> Yeah, I don't have that. Mine ends at
find fixed text.
>> Okay. Yeah. I mean other stuff you come
in later or whatever drawing tools you
think you want, but like those are like
really the main ones are like yeah like
the vertical line is how is how like you
know that F6 is how I just come in in
the morning and say okay I want a line
you know to mark those key times in the
market.
>> Okay. And then I imagine I can change
colors in something somewhere.
>> Yeah, we'll go we'll go through that
stuff in a second. So do your like pull
up a rectangle.
>> Yeah, that is F. Wait, wait. Uh before
we do that
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
>> How do I properly move this chart
around?
>> Oh, good thing you're here. Otherwise, I
don't know to tell that. Um,
okay. So, basically, you just click and
move.
>> Yeah. Which also seems like it's middle
scroll wheel.
>> It's Yeah, that seems really inefficient
for me.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> obviously,
>> but it is like locked. And so, if you
always if you scroll too far to the
side, this arrow at the top right will
pop up. You can click that and it will
always like reenter your part to that
side. Um, and if you hold control um,
and click anywhere, you can just it it
unlocks it. And then so if you go way
off the chart, this little F pops up at
the top right and then you click that
and then click the arrow and it will
totally like reset it. And then the same
thing with these, you can click and drag
the axis and you can click control and
drag just to like move it without like
scaling it. And again like you can reset
it by clicking the F button.
>> Okay. So, is there is there any way do I
have to go over the Oh gosh,
>> you can
>> do I have to go over the right hand side
to
>> to vertically move it
>> to like zoom in and out, I guess.
>> Um
there might be like No, that's Yeah,
that's pretty much zoom in and out. I
mean, I or just drag on the chart, but
like generally I would say once you like
have it set up the the way I zoom in and
out is literally just drag the bottom
because it's like that zooms out to give
you more data data. And so just dragging
the bottom will do that because it'll
then fit to the chart, you know, as it
expands to the left.
>> Yeah. Okay. Mine looks ugly. But
>> why does it look ugly? What? What's
wrong?
>> Not being able to zoom is annoying.
>> What do you need to zoom on? Like you
can zoom in by just dragging to the
right will zoom in or drag, you know,
drag to like pull the chart.
>> Yeah, I think it's really just
>> getting used to it or
>> getting used to it.
>> Okay. Yeah, because pretty much I think
all I do to zoom is just drag the bottom
axis.
>> Drag the bottom and top.
>> Yeah. I mean, I don't think I even touch
the right side really. Yeah, it it it
auto adjusts to that.
>> Wait, mine's not auto adjusting.
>> Oh, that's awkward. Did you And you The
F is clicked.
>> The F is
No, the F was not clicked. I was looking
at the little arrow thing and thought
that's what you were talking about.
Okay. Okay, we're good. That seems so
much more natural.
>> Okay. Yeah, it's not like my chart
doesn't work. I
>> What are you talking about, Riley?
>> This looks so ugly. That makes way more
sense.
>> Okay. F is your like F is essentially
recenter.
>> Yeah. F is recenter and the arrow is re
like get back.
>> Okay.
>> And it does the same if you drag to the
left. Like you go, you know, reset to
the right.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Ready for drawings?
>> Yeah. Ready for drawings.
>> Okay. So, F3 to, you know, you F3 and
then you click and then you don't need
to hold. It's just it's just a toggle.
So you click, drag, and then click again
to like finish it.
>> Yeah.
>> And then double click on it to pull up
properties. You can also right click,
but I find double clicking easier. Um,
and then this is where you can change
the settings. I just, you know, whatever
color you want. I like cyan for some
reason. And then to make it feel like a
box with strong edges is you just make
the opacity 10%. And then you just have
to make sure you click this outline
button to match the color if you want
the color to be the same. Um, and I just
keep it the same color for a support or
resistance zone because really I'm just,
you know, the idea is like this is an
area where I see it reversing and it's
easy enough to be like, oh, I see it
reversing, you know, what direction. And
then you might, you can increase this
width number to increase the like line
around the box, a solid line, but like I
find two is fine. One, you can even go
one if you want like a little more.
>> Yeah, I just left mine on two.
>> And then click this template button at
the bottom and then click save and click
save as default. So, every time you
click that hotkey and pull it up, it'll
just be those settings.
>> Oh, okay.
>> I kind of like the I'm gonna go with the
the one width for for a while. See what
that feels like. Um, and then same thing
with your line tool. F2. Same thing.
Just double click on it. Um, I just have
the the line width of two pixels. I have
it yellow. Same thing. Go to template
and then just do save. Save as default.
>> Oh, save as default. Okay. Uh, let me
>> Are you saving it as my template?
>> Yeah, the first one I definitely just
hit save and then um save as default.
Save as default. Okay, I named it
default.
>> There's a button.
>> Yeah, I did read.
>> And then I think honestly that's kind of
like I guess you could do F6 and just
click for your vertical line.
>> Yeah. And just do that while we're doing
it.
>> And just I mean my I don't know what the
default is, but I just do red.
>> Vertical line. I'm going to swap mine to
width of one and then just save as
default. And then to just get rid of any
of them, you just click on it. Click
delete button.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Um
Oh, right click on the chart and then go
to crosshair and then do local.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I this it's way easier to see where your
mouse is and also just like see I don't
know match it with what the hexaxis
>> Yeah. It let you kind
>> You could do a kind of a quick
resistance level or something.
>> Yeah. Um Okay. Oh, last thing is go to
your control window and then just go to
workspace and highlight over whatever
you named it. Like mine is new setup and
just do save. I think that'll that'll
make sure you saved everything we just
set up. So then it should theoretically
always and then when you exit this, I
think when you exit every time it'll say
save workspace and I always say yes
because then it will save like all your
drawings and stuff.
>> You've done any changes or anything? Oh,
okay. Okay. Any changes or any drawings,
it'll just keep those.
>> So you don't have to like restart every
day. Yeah.
>> Kind of like keep some of the stuff in.
Okay.
>> Yeah. Or just have whatever your Yeah.
And then you can always right click and
go to drawings and literally just remove
all drawing objects if you just want to
like get everything out, which just
sometimes works too cuz sometimes I'll
um have too much stuff on the screen.
Oh, I guess last thing I actually forgot
about. pull up your rectangles and then
this attach to I don't know if you
noticed that this was different. This
allows you to do it. So it if you click
on all charts it'll automatically so
it's up on this chart and now if you
pull up your one minute chart of the ES
>> oh it'll also be there. Okay.
>> Or here is the five minute. It'll find
it easier. It's automatically on that
chart. So that's how like you can easily
do that. So, I I have that for my my big
rectangles, but I don't have it for like
my trend lines all the time. I think I
actually do by default. Yeah. But
sometimes like if maybe you have a big
trend line on your, you know, 15-inute
chart, but then you go on a one minute
chart and, you know, you draw like a a
really small trend line. Well, it's kind
of annoying if that shows up on your,
you know,
>> it looks like just a random little tiny
line. Yeah.
>> So, you can go in and say, "Okay, well,
I want this personally one to just be
like on a one minute and then it doesn't
show."
>> Okay. And then I imagine for when you
make those changes every time, you just
need to go template save as default or
just save.
>> Um, if you want it to always be Yeah. If
you want something to always be there,
you always have to resave it as default.
>> Okay.
>> Um, I guess also because we we goofed up
and I didn't do this in the beginning,
you're going to have to go in and change
all your crosshairs on these ones to
local. you'll eventually like it it'll
be easy to do either like right now or
just
>> do I have to save in some fashion for
that or is it just good to go?
>> You can go to workspace again and just
click save.
>> Okay.
>> And make sure but again like when you
exit out of the platform
>> it'll prompt me to save.
>> It'll prompt you to save but you know
just to be safe like in case like your
thing crashes or something. Okay. Okay.
So, I guess let's start with like big
picture like support and resistance
first because those are like the most
important things is just like you know
you can see that the market just zooming
out it it's very like back and forth you
know.
>> Yeah.
>> Um especially right now like it's a very
volatile time sometimes. I don't know if
I can scroll far enough back because
we've been in pretty volatile time
recently. it's very volatile and like
because of that for for me in the
mornings I find the best thing is to um
be looking at like the extremes right
like be this is the most recent like
extreme high like if you scroll back
like the market you know topped out here
before it sold off kind of thing like in
the last I don't know what how many days
this is like a month basically um and so
it's like that's something I want to be
aware of and so I'll generally just draw
like a box from the like I'll try and be
very specific specific at the top of the
box at the high and then the bottom is
kind of subjective. Like the idea is I'm
trying to just keep track of okay these
areas like it it bounced here. You could
make a justification for pulling it all
the way down to this one but at some
point like the you know the box gets
pretty big and you you want to try and
like be sticking to the more extremes
because those are where the market's
more likely to reverse because it's kind
of overextended and in that unhealthy
situation.
>> Yeah. And for so for drawing these
you're always kind of starting at the
absolute top that the market reached.
>> Yes. Yeah. Like for your biggest big
picture like okay what is the like even
down here like I would this is where
like having those crosshairs really
comes into play. I would match this
bottom and then pull this up here.
>> Yeah. And it's never it's never like
where it closed in those candlesticks.
It's the farthest point it moved to.
>> Yeah. Because you know in a in a in a
15minute candle it's like that's a lot
of time or even if you picture you just
want to because that's like that's where
price went. That's the extreme price
went. Ideally with extremes like I'm
okay like sometimes taking in one
extreme for a zone but ideally you have
multiple touches. Like my basic rule of
thumb is like you it's nice to have two
you know like if the market was like
trading here having these two I mean
like I would draw the level kind of like
this of like okay well it's hit here
before here and here and so the next
time it comes up here I'm going to
that's that's like where I want to kind
of hone in and be aware of that okay
well it's likely to reverse in this
area. You don't have to think of like,
oh, it's hit the zone perfectly like the
bottom. I bet that it's going to like
reverse right now or I think that it's
going to reverse right now or if it's
broken it that means like it's going to
now, you know, make a big move up like
that. It it can like break out like this
and then fail back in. You know, it's
idea is it's very subjective and it's
very it's a very like loose idea of like
okay in this area and the area could
still even be larger, you know, it could
be up here.
>> Yeah. It's not it's not hard and fast.
It's like a it is more likely and
there's a higher chance that it's going
to do something in this zone.
>> Yeah. The whole idea is just to help
yourself like mark okay where are the
important areas that you need to pay
attention to. And so like even here like
this is the last like couple days. I
like to think about like the the super
extremes and then when I'm zooming in
because usually, you know, like here
it's like, well, I can't wait like it
could take days for the market to get,
you know, to hear um the this super big
high or down here, right? And it's like
there are areas in the middle, but
generally I like to be, you know,
patient with those and think of like,
okay, well, I need again like multiple
touches um for me to think about an
area. So like here it's like okay well
there's clearly like a spot here where
it's like the market keeps failing off
of
>> Yeah.
>> Um and then same down here it's like
okay well we came off this level and
it's like it can find support in the
middle where it's like okay well there
was clearly kind of a spot here where it
broke this high and then in a way like
this is like when you have trends like
it'll hit a spot like this is clearly a
resistance for some reason. sold off,
broke through it, and then it came and
like retested this area basically. And
it's almost like saying like, okay,
well, this area where it was resistance
now essentially like turns into support,
and then it comes and like it tests it
again before it, you know, you moves up.
And you can even say, so this this like
turns into almost like a stairst step
pattern where it can like, you know,
come up, come down, test, and then like
move up again and then, you know, like
it it it won't always follow it, right?
But like it changes how it like you it
moves through stuff. Um
>> yeah, that was one of my questions going
back that can resistance levels become
supports like floors.
>> Yeah. And so I I
>> Do you count that as a touch or is it
kind of just a additional thing you like
to see
>> as like this as a touch or this as a
touch?
>> Like um the left two. So where it tested
it, that one and that one. Like if you
didn't see the third one, would you
count those two? Um, I would say no in
the sense of like if you're if you're
like right here because you haven't seen
this yet. This to me feels like again
the bigger thesis is sticking to the
extremes of
>> what the current market conditions are
and obviously like those are always
changing um of where the extremes are as
you know the market moves up and down
you know like and so as the market moves
up here like this was an extreme but as
it breaks up here and then bounces here
now it's here like if you kind of look
at this of like okay this is kind of
like the range it's
This kind of feels more towards the
center. Like I would start to think that
this is more the extreme and down here
is the extreme. And this is kind of
you're getting into the center where
it's a lot harder to be correct about
>> what's going to happen. It's so easy to
get in, you know, where it just starts
chopping or or going back and forth. Um
and so that's why I try and stick away
from that. So, I wouldn't use this as a
level I think until when I was looking
at this like it's this is kind of the
overnight like let's see right like
here's this is the overnight session of
that day and so
>> but like without thinking about that
like yeah I I don't think I'd use this
because at this point I'm starting to
think of this as an extreme and then as
it plays out you know then you you get
to a point where it's like okay now I I
can I have enough information to start
to realize okay what is the new extremes
like that's the hard part about trading
sometimes is you'll be bouncing between
like this was clearly in a range from
like here to here for a couple days and
then it bounces up here and kind of goes
in this range for a couple days. And so
it's about like adjusting identifying,
okay, we're breaking out of this. I
can't bet lower anymore, but now I have
to like almost wait for more data to be
able to find, okay, this is maybe the
new range that we're trading in. Yeah,
that was one of I mean I saw a Discord
comment from the other day that was like
I'm seeing support levels everywhere.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And part of what I was thinking of when
going through one of your lectures was
the like where where are you determining
or like what time frame are you
determining the major support zones on?
Cuz yeah, like as you were talking
about, we had that first one that kind
of hits those three points, but then it
looks like it forms one above it, but is
that still all in the middle of the two
larger ones?
>> Are you talking about this one?
>> Yeah. So, there's like that one and then
there's the second from the top support
level that you drew. That one,
>> the resistance level.
>> So, um the one down.
>> Oh, this one.
>> So, there's that one. But is that then
like is that in the middle of the one
below it and the one all the way down?
>> Right. Yeah. So it's it is kind of like
you're looking at the extremes extremes
and then you're kind of because that
that that's kind of like really big
picture.
>> Yeah.
>> And because you know trading on a one
minute chart like that trade we started
with um was literally I bought here and
sold here.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it's and you know that was a
plenty of move for a trade, right? And
so it's like you're because you're in
such like a focus and smaller time
frame, you can trade these smaller
extremes and smaller brackets.
>> Yeah. And those larger ones would be
like, "Okay, we're trading overnight."
Like that's a fiveday trade or
something.
>> Yeah. And and I mean like I still would
use these levels to take a trade off of
like getting in here and like you know
catching this up. That would be huge.
Um,
>> but you're not waiting you're not
waiting for your one minute chart to go
all the way back down there.
>> No, I'm definitely like every Yeah,
every day is like once it, you know, I'm
not taking a trade here and like
catching a move because it's, you know,
I needed more time to figure out, okay,
this is actually a level I like.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, because it's there's, you
know, this this level, this bounce, this
bounce, and then this bounce. Yeah.
>> That gave me enough reason to be like,
okay, there's kind of a support level
here.
>> There's something there. Okay. and you
know like a trend line came into play as
well like off of these these two right
here really um and then also like the
the ES chart kind of looked the same and
so um there's you know other things that
we'll talk about that went into that it
takes some time to learn to do that
because also then you can go into you
know your five minute chart and
sometimes I'll do the five-minute chart
to be looking at those levels because
you can see them um you know zooming
that back out for those multiple days is
kind of hard but like if the market was
opening here. You know, it's pretty easy
to say, okay, well, there's a nice clean
double bottom here that I could say
there's a potential support here.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> tested it twice.
>> Yeah. And there's kind of a high right
here, you know, and especially Okay.
Well, there's another swing here, so I
can definitely draw kind of a box based
on those. But also, you know, like
you're saying, like you don't want to
over complicate things. Sometimes it's
like without trying to just say like,
oh, this like this kind of comes with
experience of like trying to figure out
um and and reading the levels of like,
okay, now it's like this level maybe
isn't as good anymore or like, you know,
based on what's like you can start to
understand when a level is like a really
solid level and when it's starting to
like it's not very strong or something.
And I think just going through examples
and stuff, we'll we'll pull out why
that's the case.
>> For this one here, that second two
points where it's touching,
>> which zone, one, two, or three?
>> Um, where it's touching two, the two
recent ones
>> here.
>> Would that be a good spot? Cuz it looks
like it's doing its whole double bottom
thing. But are you looking for
>> more of a touch or
>> I think you could enter in here. No,
this I think this is totally fine of a
touch if you're saying like, oh, it
barely touched the zone or or kind of
didn't.
>> Yeah. No, I think it's totally fine.
Like again, it's like it's super
subjective. Like you could have drawn
the level like right up here.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, sometimes I'll think oh like
sometimes I'll take in like oh this is
like a little chop range that it had.
Yeah.
>> So almost like think of this as like a
little box where the market came down
and bottomed
>> kind of consolidated.
>> Yeah. And so take that into account and
draw my box including that.
>> Okay.
>> Um but again, you don't want to get too
crazy like this one up here. I don't
want to take in this whole box because
then you pull the box like
>> all the way down and it's
>> Yeah, it's almost in the middle of the
flipping range here. If you stick to the
extremes, like your box is all the way
down here, you know. Um, so you want to
be aware of that when you're drawing
that kind of stuff, too.
>> Okay.
>> Um, and then trend lines, I would say,
are pretty similar. You know, you can
have, you know, like I I think they're
pretty subjective as well, and I try and
do them pretty loosely of like, hey, you
have a swing here and a touch here. And
so, you know, I'm going to draw a line
off of that and just pull it out. And,
you know, I like to do try and do the
extreme of the initial one, like the
extreme price, and then just touch
somewhere on here. Usually try and stick
to the extreme if that makes sense. And
then, you know, this it's like, hey,
it's close to the trend line. you know,
there's not an easy way to like make a a
a rectangle like we have for the
>> yeah zones that trends like that. Um, so
I just try and use it like, hey, it's
close. That's another indicator that I
can say, you know, especially with
confirming that with like, oh, I kind of
have like a low here and a a support
zone that I think might bounce to, you
know, after this bounce is made, you can
then say, okay, well, it bounced here.
I'm going to adjust this to take that
into account. And it's like it's fine if
it cuts through like this candlestick
>> side. You're you're a little bit kind of
using like the mean.
>> Yeah.
>> Or like the average.
>> Yeah. Because the you know the market
doesn't that's why it's like I draw the
zones. You don't want to draw like a
specific price and be like okay well the
market has to come up and touch this
exactly to reverse for me to that's not
really how it works.
>> Yeah.
>> I think something that has kind of been
helpful for me when thinking about this
is just being like this is all
behavior-based. like this is people
reacting and doing things.
>> Yeah. I mean that's a huge thing why
like um like I don't know for an example
here like the market bounces here at
this specific price and then it goes
comes up again and people are like oh I
I really like this spot to bet that it's
going to go lower but I'm going to get
in early because I think it'll reverse
before that or or I want to get in
before it starts reversing. Yeah.
>> And so it pushes it lower earlier.
>> Yeah. And so that's why it's like stuff
can, you know, reverse in the same area
but not the exact price.
>> It's not exact same point for price.
>> Yeah. Um, and so yeah, trend lines I use
like kind of the same thing of like you
have your like there was kind of a big
picture trend line here of like taking
this extreme high and then touching
these two and then you know this was
kind of like with a little bit you could
see it like right here like oh we did a
big punch up like this is pretty like
kind of through those areas and it's
like okay might sell off here. Um
>> and then you know it it broke it a
little bit but it still kind of sold
off.
>> Yeah. and then eventually, you know, it
kind of went sideways and eventually
broke it. Like that's a lot of times how
things happen is they'll start to go
sideways and then break or something. It
won't always if it breaks, it doesn't
necessarily mean it's just going to like
start skyrocketing.
>> Yeah. It seems like the market likes to
try and think about it for a second.
>> Yeah. Sometimes
>> unless it has a shitload of momentum.
>> Yeah. And then same thing on just like
you know using that on like a smaller
time frame chart using it as a guide to
say like okay there's this like really
tight downtrend and now it's broken. And
so because of that it's like the trend
is probably going to change but it
doesn't mean that it's not going to
continue lower. It could just continue
lower and like like sometimes you'll
have like a super tight trend like this.
you'll have like a trend line and then
it will break, but then it will just be
like, oh, it's actually starting like
this bigger downtrend that's more
healthier downtrend that has like this
kind of trend line that matches what
it's doing
>> or essentially it's kind of like
consolidating and thinking about it and
then going lower again and then thinking
about it again.
>> Yeah. Like it's just it's having a
pullback is a healthy part of the
market. Yeah. Um and that's like what
what um kind of I think the next thing
is so like you know in your first week
is like looking at those big picture
levels but then between them you know
like what'll really help is like oh if
the market's going to like break a level
or not um is having stuff like you know
you have I think try and go down a list
of like I think you have something like
you have a healthy trend you can have
and a healthy trend I would say is like
something like this that's just like
methodical and almost like having that
um like that stairst step pattern
essentially. Now it doesn't necessarily
mean like
>> or the like flag shape.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean a a pullback can be
like this one like it's it's kind of
just like consolidating and pulling back
a little bit before it continues. Yeah.
Like here it's like great example like
move up consolidation and the strength
in that is like it slows down but it
doesn't go down.
>> Yeah. And so that shows you a lot of
strength of like, oh, it's it's likely
if it's not going to like fail and give
this move back up, it's likely to keep
going because that means there's a lot
of momentum and the buyers aren't drying
up. They're actually continuing. Um, and
so that's like a really strong trend I
would say. And how like an easy way to
see when it's going to end is when you
start to see like a change of like,
okay, there's
>> a big big kind of candle.
>> This is Yeah. Like this is a big change.
Like there was any time in this trend
there was no like pullback that was like
huge like that. Like this was the
biggest pullback and it was a lot more
stable and and then eventually like it
rocketed up and here it's like okay it
pulls back and just cuz you see that
it's like you don't you're not going to
short but like it's an indication that
it's something's changing.
>> Yeah. Like it spent because what each
one of those blocks is five minutes so
it spent
>> 15 minutes slowly ticking up and then
>> Yeah. I mean like it
>> dropped in five minutes. Yeah, I mean
this is a one minute chart, but like
yeah, it doesn't matter. Like it could
be
>> Oh, yeah. No, sorry. Sorry. I was
talking about the larger grid squares.
>> Um, and so that's like the biggest thing
I think is like just when you're
watching the charts in the morning is
like looking at like, okay, what is what
type of move is happening? Like this is
this was Friday and so it's like market
opens up here at 9:30 and then like this
is another thing you're going to have to
easily identify is like okay, it's just
going into chop. like it's getting used
to like seeing that print and you know
after the fact it's easy to tell okay it
was choppy here but like when the market
opens it's like starting to recognize
that of like okay we're like just having
these swings back and forth and a lot of
time it's like the candlesticks are kind
of really close to each other and like
not really moving and like the wicks are
very large I mean the general like you
know it doesn't have to be like super
technical it's just like realizing that
hey in reality like the market's really
not going anywhere, you know? It's not
really trending. It's it's just a lot of
all over the place, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And then it like clearly starts to move
and and this could be this I would
almost say is more likely a strong trend
because even though you don't have any
pullbacks in it,
>> they're big wicks.
>> The Yeah, you can say like here it's
like in these two candlesticks, the
market did move up and and make actually
a massive pullback.
>> Yeah. you know, like here that was a big
pullback. And um I would say a lot of
the time when the market opens and chops
for like 30 minutes, you know, you could
even say like, okay, it was chopping
like for 20 minutes, 25 minutes, like
it's it's gaining its momentum, you
know, it's kind of like sitting there
getting ready.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it does make the potential for a
move like this to be stronger. And so
then, you know, it like when it comes up
to I think I got to redraw this. I think
it was this, you know, essentially like,
you know, here's our resistance zone,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> And so when it comes up here of being
like, okay, we're close to it. This is
where you might think of it. It could
reverse because it's at these highs
where it's reversed multiple times
before. You know, you think, well, it's
consolidated here. It's moved up. In
reality, like big picture, like you'll
get used more used to this. This isn't
that that large of a move.
>> It's not. No, it's not that big of a
deal.
>> Yeah, because that was that was gonna be
my question of like it almost looks like
it's done a little double bottomish
almost in that like first 30 minutes.
Yeah.
>> And like then is that 9
>> 50 or 95 when you start seeing it
ticking up? Is that ever a spot where
you're like, "Okay, I'm going to hop
in." Or is it just it's not at the
bottom?
>> I wouldn't I that's not how I trade.
Like I want to see a move like this that
I think is unhealthy that I think is
going to fail. Okay.
>> To me, this is just like I'm staying
out.
>> That's the That's just the starting what
it's doing.
>> And it's like the market there will be
plenty of days where the market opens up
choppy and it just doesn't do anything
and I just get off for the day, you
know? Yeah.
>> And here you can also see it's it's
making this like consolidating wedge.
>> Yeah.
>> And so that's just kind of like at that
point it's like, oh, okay, if you were
like taking a big picture bias of like,
well, it's at the support zone, so I
think it's more likely to go up. you you
totally there are definitely people that
would take that. That's just not
something I like to do.
>> You're looking for higher level
probability.
>> Yeah. And I just think that um I like to
see the move happen in the day versus it
cuz you don't know. It could just kind
of continue to chop.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> And so Yeah. Yeah, I mean I think like
but you know there can be trades like
this trends where it's like okay if we
go to the I think the day before here
this is actually the trade that I took
is like where the market let's see
opened up right here at 9:30 and it just
kind of sold off and I you know part of
it's like okay this isn't like a super
unhealthy trend like it does have
pullbacks in it. Um, but then it just
starts to go super choppy here. Yeah.
And then eventually, like, you know, I
guess there was indicators of I thought
like, okay, well, I think it's slowing
down and it's going to like reverse
higher. Um,
>> but, you know, every time with these is
like you want to you don't want to be
thinking that it's going to reverse
until like this trend is broken.
>> Yeah. Until you see something actually
happen. Um because just because it's
like at a level doesn't mean it could it
could just keep kind of trending down
like bouncing off of this trend line.
And so that's kind of like a a big
indication of like you're using these
bigger picture levels that you draw
earlier to then go into a one minute
chart and watch like okay how is the
market moving today and how is it
reacting when it hits this level and
like what does the trend look like? Um,
and you don't have to always know, you
know, like there's plenty of times where
I'm like, I don't have a good read on
what's going on. Um, I can't tell if the
trend is healthy or it's not or just for
some reason it's just being really
jittery and I I, you know, don't feel
like I have a good read. And that's
okay. Like there's the idea is to be
only trading or making trades when
you're like, "Okay, I have a really
clear understanding of what's going on.
I'm super confident in this like zone
being a good zone and then also my read
of the market. What's it doing today?
>> Yeah,
>> that's why I like to wait for like I
don't take a trade at the market open.
Like the first time I'll take a trade is
like that 9:45 that 15 minutes after the
market open time because it gives you
time to see, you know, okay, what is the
market doing this morning? What's it
done so far? You know, it opened at this
high. I don't think this was a zone yet.
Yeah, it was like the market moved up
here, kind of chopped, attempted to go
higher, and then it essentially just
opened up and started selling off. But
like this isn't like a super unhealthy.
It's like kind of down a little bit and
it's chopping a little bit. And so it's
like, okay, I don't have a good read.
Like I don't have a good read. I'm just
going to let it keep printing until
either I do have a good read and there
it's fitting in an area that I want to
trade. Like right here, it's like, okay,
I have this zone down here. I would if
it sells off in a good way and sets up,
you know, a head and shoulders pattern
or a pattern
>> for that zone. Is that a future zone
though?
>> Yeah. I mean, like it's we don't have to
get into like, you know,
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Like I think this is just more of like
theoretical.
>> Yeah.
>> Um of like it coming down to this zone
and you know, you essentially trying to
have a plan of what I want to see to
take a trade when it gets there versus
just kind of waiting for it to happen.
Um, and you'll get better at that as you
get better at like seeing what these
trends look like. But, you know, here
being like, okay, there's not it's not a
I don't have enough information or I
don't have enough good enough read and
it's not acting how I want. Like,
there's not enough move here to make a
reversal. And obviously, it's not at
it's not at a zone that I like.
>> Yeah.
>> And then when it gets down to there,
then you can start to say, okay, now I
do, and you know, here's like more that
10:00 timing of, okay, now I do have
more information. But then also you're
like, "Okay, well now there's this
>> now there's a trend
>> make this trend line and I need to see
that broken."
>> Yeah.
>> Um and so here, you know, it just starts
to go into a chopfest of just candle
after candle just not doing anything. Um
and you're like, "Okay, well it's going
to break this trend, but I got to be
aware of that. I I need a little bit
more movement to happen kind of thing."
Um
and so like I don't like to enter in on
stuff like this. I need to see it start
to break. You can start to like with
these little chop zones, you can almost
make sometimes like sometimes I'll just
make like a I'll just do this in my head
a lot of time, but you can make like a
little box.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, of like something that just
like makes it so it's like okay, there's
just like this little box here and I
need to wait for it to break out of this
cuz then it's broken out of this like
area that it's clearly not doing
anything cuz otherwise you'll in these
chop ranges you'll get these like big
candlesticks that'll
>> it looks like something's happening but
>> Yeah. And in reality, it's like it's
still staying in this range.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and then it kind of breaks out and
does like a you know, I don't want to
get into this too much, but like a fake
lower and then that that fake lower gets
reversed and then that was like kind of
the signal that I was like, okay, now I
think it has a potential to reverse.
>> It's tested again.
>> Yeah. Again, that's more like entry
stuff. The idea is like, okay, the big
picture. And that's like the idea is
like you're slowly going more narrower
and narrower focused as you kind of get
into these areas of like okay what is
you know the big picture like zone that
I'm getting from a 15-minute chart or a
five minute and then either on a on a
you know you could also go to a five
minute and look at this of like okay
what is like what what have we done
we've done a big move this morning into
basically like you know here is like
kind of more of that zone I was looking
at that day okay it's kind bottom tier
and there was also this this upward
trend line farther back. Yeah.
>> And so it's like okay those are like two
kind of it's kind of theoretically
bouncing off this little swing here and
then it's also like hitting this trend
line. Um and then you know going into
kind of the one minute chart and seeing
like okay what's the trend and seeing
that it's kind of bottoming at that
10:00 time which is that timing that I
really like of when stuff reverses and
then seeing like even just the big
picture of like okay there was a
downtrend. It's clearly lost its steam.
What's likely to happen at this area?
You don't have to be thinking about this
like what the candlesticks are doing
specifically. Just like you could almost
even like blur your eyes of like, okay,
we're down. We're kind of sideways and
we're at an area where I think there's
going to be upwards pressure. Well, then
it's likely that we go up, whatever that
looks like.
>> And then what am I looking for?
>> Yeah. And then when we get into like the
entry, it's like, okay, what am I
looking for to actually enter in a trade
of like where I enter and like where I
put my stop loss kind of thing and write
it up.
>> Okay. Well, I know you don't have a lot
more time, right?
>> Yeah. Um,
>> so for this week,
>> well, I guess Yeah, it's like um cuz I
was trying to I guess does that make
sense with like trends? Um, I mean it's
like I think just this week there's, you
know, there's going to be like like this
is like this is like a super strong
trend, you know, like like we kind of
had originally of like it's not really
having pullbacks and then you can have
trends where it's like, you know, like
this one, it's like it's super strong,
but it's kind of unhealthy of like it's
a huge move. And so it's like it it has
a more likelihood to fail, but you just
have to you don't know sometimes where
that is. And so I think in the morning
trying to just get good at identifying
what kind of
>> healthy unhealthy. Is there a way to put
in text boxes onto this and just like
right click text box?
>> Right click drawing tools text.
>> Okay. Um,
>> so maybe I'll try and go through and
just like put in resistance zones or put
in floors and ceilings or resistance and
whatever the other word that I can't
think of right now and then trend lines
and then put some trend lines in and
then try and label them healthy,
unhealthy.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And you could like try and
take pictures um and put them in like a
folder or something. Uh, another thing I
like to do like a super easy way of
doing this is just with like an
indicator. If you go I don't put this on
my my one minute charts. I like to do it
on a five minute is if you just go to
your five minute chart and go up here to
indicators. I don't know why this little
square circle keeps turning off. And
then in the box just type in don't know
how to spell like fair to bring up fair
value gap. Or you can just type in gap
or something.
>> Oh yeah.
>> And that'll bring up this indicator
called the fair value gap indicator and
you just click apply without changing
any settings and it will help
essentially identify like unhealthy
moves in the market. Yeah. Should I
start with that on or leave it off so
that I'm not relying on it as much?
>> That's a good question.
>> I think I'm going to start with it off
so that I can try and do my best and
gain some intuition and then
>> it's not going to be right every time.
Like this was, you know, this it's
saying there's an unhealthy move here.
And this was that that move here we were
looking at earlier where it's like, you
know, there was there was definitely
reasons to say it could have been an
unhealthy move, but I think there was,
you know, other reasons to think it
wasn't. And so,
>> and then it kind of did that little
consolidation thing there. Yeah, I did
this little pullback and then kept going
higher and um yeah, so yeah, I think
that's totally a reasonable thing to do
is like leave it off because I mean at
the end of the day like yeah, you can
see it's pretty easy to see like okay
this is a big move down. We need to give
that back up or like this is a big move
down. It's like the basics is like,
okay, are there a bunch of candlesticks
in one direction without like much
pullbacks essentially like, you know,
like the bodies are just all stacked up
on each other just moving up.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's just all it's just one
directional, you know, like that's like
the easy way to say and like the whole
idea behind these unhealthy moves is
like, okay, it moves up crazy. Well, it
has to kind of pull back.
up crazy and it kind of has to pull back
or or the flip side of it like a crazy
sell off it has to kind of give that
back up to some extent. Yeah. This week
is like just trying to get in that
routine of like pulling up your like
15-minute chart, looking at, you know,
kind of what's going on, trying to think
about the trends and stuff of like what
what you're seeing and then just seeing
what that's like. And then also, you
know, doing that on a five minute,
trying to think of your support and
resistance levels and looking
>> for for drawing support and resistance
and trends. You're generally doing
support levels on a 15minute chart,
right?
>> Yeah. Like sometimes I'll look at a
five, but like quite often even the five
minute ones, you know, like even these
swings, like you can tell it's on a on a
15-inute chart that there's, you know,
like this support level,
>> something there. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Like you can still
>> Yeah. And then I imagine you're never
really drawing them on a one minute cuz
it's just
>> No, I think Yeah.
>> Too too far in.
>> Yeah. You're too zoomed in and that at
that point you're not looking, you know,
it's not you're not using the like big
thesis of like, oh, I'm sticking to the
extremes.
>> Yeah. Are you drawing what levels are
you drawing trends at? All levels.
>> Trend lines.
>> Trend lines. Yeah.
>> Um, yeah, I would say so. Because I I
like to think though like trend lines
are a lot of like helping you identify
like the big picture that's going on.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, of like, okay, here there was
this like trend line up that was going
on.
>> Yeah.
>> But also like try to not just say, okay,
we're in an uptrend. Think about it like
here it's like okay it's trending up but
it's starting to make
>> yeah tops
>> tops and like it's starting to reverse
in the same area and so when that
happens well it's probably going to
break this at some point and so trying
to think about stuff like that too of
like you know don't get married to a
drawing tool it's all subjective at the
end of the day and you know stuff like
that you know next week we'll we can get
into I think more of the nitty-gritty of
like trying to enter in and stuff like
that because I think you know it's it's
I don't think you need to start doing it
this week, but at that point, you know,
it's it's helpful to just even start
learning like what it feels like to just
even just the controls of all that
stuff.
>> Um, so I've watched the I don't know
what is it the course overview, I guess
the the section one and two in your
course. Should I watch section three
this week in preparation for the
following week or just hold off? Most of
that that's like um how to enter into
trades properly, my phase three
management blah blah blah and then a
bunch of like trade walkthroughs.
>> Um I don't know. I think we can just
hold off on that. Yeah.
>> Okay. Stick to the basics.
>> Yeah.
>> Don't over like you're just you're
getting ahead of the game of like Yeah.
You're not even thinking you're not even
starting to enter in yet. Like I think
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Because it's like the the big picture
and just learning to read the big
picture is literally going to be like
90% of your success.
>> Yeah. just being able to pick the right
zones to reverse at and be able to pick
and understand like okay what is the
trend like why you know why that you
know it's reversed here multiple times
why this time is it going to push higher
you know
>> yeah managing trades doesn't really
matter if you're not trading in the
right spot
>> yeah like and 90% of your trading is
your entries and so and and your entries
are based on your thesis of what the
market's going to do from that area and
So getting that down is like the most
important thing about trading. Like it's
so many people get distracted by all the
other stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> That's why I think so many people
overload and then they realize, oh, I
need to go the simple route and just go
back to the basics almost.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Keep it simple, stupid. But
should I be trying to do or maybe I just
try um like little market thesises of
like I think it's going to do this here
at all of like oh it's approaching a
resistance level. I think it might do
this or I think it might do that. like
kind of almost like you're not entering
in a trade, but you're saying, "Oh, I
think it's gonna bounce here."
>> Yeah. Or I think it's gonna do this. And
maybe it's something I try and think
about, but like
>> Yeah. Like you could even like something
like this. You could type like, "Okay, I
think we're at here. You know, I think
we're because of these reasons, I think
we're going to go up."
>> Yeah. or like like you know this trade
like you came down here and you had that
like support zone and that resistance
zone and you could say like type in like
reverse up you know something like that.
>> Put in put in some thoughts.
>> Yeah. like reverse up, you know, because
of I think probably saying like because
of blank will help you get in the mode
of like why do you think that, you know,
versus like just because you don't want
to just start randomly thinking that and
then because even if you're not in a
trade, you're still going to get like
kind of some confirmation bias if you're
right or wrong.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh yeah, I was right. Yeah.
>> Yeah. it'll just be random thoughts that
pop in your head, you know, and so
trying to just think of like, okay,
well, I think it's gonna even if it's
like, oh, I think the trend's going to
just start chopping here. And you could
always change it as like more
candlesticks come out. Yeah.
>> Like, oh, it's like moving. I think it's
going to reverse up now or or I think
it's going to like fake higher and then
go lower. Stuff like that.
>> Okay. I will try and Yeah, I'll go
through and do that.
>> Okay. I guess we will reconvene next
week.
>> Yep. Now, if you want more of an
explanation on futures and how they work
so you can get started, check out this
video right here or check out the next
session that I did with my brother so
you can start building that foundation
and stacking on it yourself and
approaching trading in a methodical,
clean manner.